Oh
Ah
Wisst ihr was wir schreiben jetzt jeden Abend an wenn es Probleme gibt
Wir schreiben die jeden Abend auf Twitter an jeden Abend wenn es Probleme gibt schreiben wir die an
Wir schreiben die jeden Abend an ich kopiere mir gerade noch den Screenshot rüber
Ich kopiere mir gerade noch den Screenshot rüber und gehe den damit auf den Sack
Ah
Kann ich das nicht anhängen ist jetzt auch Twitter kaputt oder was
Geht es jetzt eigentlich wieder halbwegs
So an was schreibt man jetzt Vodafone Vodafone Service
Ich glaube Vodafone Service Unity Media Hilfe war es früher jetzt ist es glaube ich Vodafone Service
Die sind eigentlich recht fix ich weiß aber die können nichts machen
So
Jetzt
Alter
Okay
Wieder am Start
Das machen wir jetzt jeden Tag Leute jeden Tag wenn es rumsparkt
So das machen wir jetzt das machen wir jetzt jeden Tag
Selbst wenn ich die wie gesagt ich bin ja da nicht irgendwie jetzt auf den Anbieter so scharf da zu bleiben
Aber
Was wollte ich sagen
Aber ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken dass solange die Vertragslaufzeit halt noch ist dass sie das irgendwie gefixt kriegen
Ja und wenn nicht dann schreibe ich das den jeden Abend dass sie im Zweifelsfall sage ich denen danach ein paar Wochen Jungs also
Ihr habt jetzt 20 mal versucht das zu fixen es hat nicht funktioniert jetzt kündige ich das
Wahrscheinlich muss man sie dann auch offiziell in Verzug setzen so nach dem Motto ich gebe euch Zeit bis da und dann Abhilfe zu schaffen was auch immer
Das werde ich dann machen aber ich will ja dass es zumindest bis sie dass sie einfach für ihr Geld was machen ja
Kann doch nicht sein
Ich habe gelesen ich habe gelesen dass das angeblich eine Connect Box liegt
Ich kann auch nicht meine Antwort auf Twitter posten weil Twitter hängt
Aber das machen wir jetzt jeden Abend immer wenn es leckt ohne Scheiß das machen wir immer wenn das Stream ab bricht weil es leckt
Aha Aha ich sehe es schon Leute hier was da los was ist da los immer wenn es leckt poste ich an Vodafone immer
Scheiß drauf ich spam die jetzt den ganzen Abend zu die kriegen jedes Mal einen Screenshot der Screenshot sagt zwar überhaupt nichts aus
Letztendlich der Screenshot sagt nur aus dass ich Fremdrops des Todes habe die kriegen das jedes Mal ich werde die so voll spammen
Ja ich bin ja nicht mal wirklich ländliche Region
Okay wir ignorieren das jetzt einfach mal wir gucken mal ob Vodafone antwortet gucken wir gucken nachher noch mal rein was Vodafone geschrieben hat
Wir machen jetzt erstmal weiter also was waren das letzte was ihr gehört habt von dem was ich erzählt habe bevor das Stream abgekackt ist
Das Firmware Update irgendwas mit Firmware Update habe ich erzählt stimmt's
Was für eine Leitung 440 ab ich bezahle Power Upload auch noch doppelt
Hast du eine Idee warum ein Windows nach einer neuen Installation manchmal kurz hängen bleibt also so 5 bis 10 Sekunden
Festplatten einhängen vielleicht Mountest du irgendwelche Nasslaufwerke oder externe Platten oder interne Platten die erst anlaufen müssen oder so
Ansonsten keine Ahnung
Gut also ich war stehen geblieben bei Firmware Updates genau
Sprich das Ding hier kümmert sich um Firmware Updates und nachdem ich schon mal Probleme hatte genau genau jetzt weiß ich wieder was ich sagen sollte
Kauft ihr ein Cisco Modem das Ding ist echt... ich brauch kein Cisco Modem wozu
Ich brauch einen ordentlichen Provider
So jetzt stell euch mal vor zum Beispiel ihr habt den Controller irgendwo also das Ding
Ihr habt das irgendwo im Keller hängen das heißt wo ihr nicht so einfach dran kommt für neue Firmware
Und ihr flasht das und ihr habt einen Bug drinne und zwar habt ihr einen Bug hier drinne
Irgendein Nullpointer oder sowas irgendwas was dir halt mit C++ und C ab und zu mal passieren kann
Dann ist das Problem dass der Server crasht bevor ihr ein weiteres Firmware Update hochladen könnt
Deswegen habe ich das hier eingebaut das heißt nach einem Neustart das Ding crasht ja nach einem Neustart
Nach einem Neustart warte ich fünf Sekunden und in der Zeit kann ich ein Firmware Update anfangen
Und wenn ich ein Firmware Update angefangen habe innerhalb dieser fünf Sekunden dann macht er auch nicht weiter
Das heißt er fängt mit der Hauptschleife überhaupt nicht an bevor das Firmware Update nicht fertig ist
Das heißt so kann ich mich nicht aussperren das habe ich eingebaut weil ich damit schon mal Probleme hat
Ich habe ein Firmware Update hochgeladen auf den Controller Firmware Update ist immer kaputt
Und ich muss das Ding erstmal wieder anschließen an PC
Also Umut wenn das wirklich damit zusammenhängt kann schon sein
Ich habe nämlich auch gelesen dass viele Leute davon betroffen sind vor allem viele die eine Connectbox haben
Deswegen habe ich mir schon überlegt ob ich mir mal gucken wo davon geantwortet hat
Deswegen habe ich mir auch schon überlegt ob ich mir nicht jetzt tatsächlich mal eine Kabelfritzbox hole
Das würde sich bei mir anbieten auch wenn ich kein all zu großer Fritzbox Fan bin was die Fritzbox als Router anbelangt
Als Multifunktionsgerät ist die Fritzbox super aber ich will sie auch als Multifunktionsgerät verwenden
Denn bei mir ist es ja aktuell so ich habe die Connectbox, ich habe meinen Mikrotik Router
Und ich habe noch eine Fritzbox für SIP, VoIP und Telefoniegeschichten und Fax
Aber Fax verwende ich nicht aber Fax würde das auch machen
Das heißt ich verwende eh schon genau Deckt von der Fritzbox genau dafür verwende ich es auch
Das heißt ich brauche eh eine Fritzbox für Deckt für VoIP für SIP und Gedöns
So und nachdem ich eh eine Fritzbox brauche würde es sich anbieten die Connectbox einfach komplett rauszuschmeißen
Und eine Fritzbox zu holen die eben Deckt SIP Gedöns macht plus halt Kabel Internet Kram
Warum nicht? Mein Mikrotik Router bleibt weiterhin dahinter und macht halt alles was ein Router so macht und Gutes
Umut was hast du denn für einen Modem? Zeig mal gucken
Ah ich sehe Baro muss nicht gucken ich schaue zwischendurch ab und zu mal rein ich kriege ja auch eine Nachricht auf das Handy das liegt da neben mir
Willst du die haben denn ich kaufe mir irgendeine
Was taugt denn da was kauft man sich da so AVM.de Kabel Fritzbox so Produkte Fritzbox
Mein Vater das muss ich immer dran denken bei Fritzbox
Mein Vater hat nicht gecheckt dass das Ding Fritzbox heißt er hat immer gesagt Fritzi Box
Und der hat sich das nicht ausreden lassen also ich kriege schon mit wenn es wirklich abkackt
Er hat immer gesagt Fritzi Box und die schlimmste Kombination war es war ja bei der Fritzbox früher Fritz Fax dabei der hat noch Faxe geschickt
Hätte er wenigstens Fritzi Fax gesagt das wäre dann irgendwie noch konsistent gewesen
Aber nein er hat immer gesagt dann Fritze Fax und das hat mich komplett fertig gemacht
Wir haben die Wörter wehgetan ich hab gesagt alter sprecht den Scheiß doch mal richtig aus
Fritzi Box und Fritze Fax
So Fritz Box was ist da Kabel hier Kabel warum gibt es denn warum gibt es denn 7000er nicht für Kabel
Warum gibt es bei 7000er nur nicht Kabel warum ist das so AVM Anzeige ist raus
Oh zum Thema Anzeige ist raus
Habt ihr diesen komplett unsinnigen Beef mitgekriegt mit Montana Black und irgendwie dieser Böhmermann Truppe da
Was ein Schwachsinn wieder oh meine Fresse ey
Das Flagship ist Kabel 6591 seid froh wenn ihr das nicht mitgekriegt habt 6591
Haben die haben die irgendwas so einen Vergleich was was ist kann man
Ah Produkt vergleichen ah yes excellent
Also was haben wir hier zur Auswahl Doxys 3 1
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Doxys 3 1 und Doxys 3 0
Wahrscheinlich die Geschwindigkeit
Was braucht man denn Doxys 3 0
Wobei das steht hier doch bestimmt dabei was das kann WLAN juckt mich überhaupt nicht
Ah guck mal die 666 ist besser als die 6591 passt ja auch ist ja auch größer die Nummer
WLAN brauche ich überhaupt nicht von der Fritzbox
So das heißt die ganzen WLAN Gedöns brauche ich nicht juckt mich absolut gar nicht
Das ist WLAN was ist das für ein Speed was soll das sein
Abdaun oder was Maximum Dauner Maximum Was Was
Aber dann würde es keinen Sinn machen weil das 3 0 ist und das gleiche hier ist
Ach das ist WLAN ok ja ok theoretischer WLAN Speed der eh nicht erreicht wird
Telefonanlage bla bla bla bla 2,5 Gigabit LAN brauche ich da dran nicht
Brauche ich an meinem NAS und das hat eine 10G Karte drin
LAN LAN LAN USB USB
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe kann ich die billigste Kabel Fritzbox kaufen für meine Zwecke
Was die 666 hat irgendwelche Features nicht ne doch ISDN hat die nicht ISDN hat die nicht
Aber ISDN brauche ich nicht
Das heißt ich kann die aller billigste Fritzbox kaufen ok die hier kann ich kaufen
WLAN brauche ich nämlich nicht Telefonanlage
Hast du denn 3 1 keine Ahnung wo sehe ich das
Kein Schimmer
Ist das in der Connectbox was ich also damit kenne ich mich echt nicht aus
Ok ich gucke mir jetzt mal an den Cisco Modem an
3.1 aber gehe ich richtig in der Annahme dass wenn ich einen 3.0 Anschluss habe und mir eine 3.1 Fritzbox habe
Dass das Abwärtskompatibel ist
Ja ja komm scheiß drauf dann
Ok wir gucken mal was der preisliche Unterschied ist
Fritzbox 666
Alter was ist mit euch los ey
230 Euro was kosten die andere
Was kosten die 230 Euro
Was kosten diese andere Dings hier 6591 mal das
Wo ist die überhaupt
Oder was 6590
Gibt es nicht
Warum gibt es die nicht
Dann kaufe ich halt die da bleibt nicht das ist das Modem vom Umut
Also wenn ich doppelte fürs Modem bezahle
Das ist es mir dann auch nicht wert das ist halt Cisco Zeug das muss halt teuer sein
E-Trading Store klingt
Super vertrauenserweckend ok also kauft man eine Fritzbox 6666
Nee nicht der Teufel hier die da kaufen war da
So was
Warum
Der Teufel ja das das ist auch AVM wird ja auch in manchen Kreisen oft als die rote Pest bezeichnet
Notebooks billiger
Bei denen habe ich öfters gekauft
Die klingen so gebated der Shop aber die sind ganz gut
Die kaufen wir
So aber die 6 die andere kann ich nicht mehr kaufen weil die hat ja auch
Das sind ja die einzigen mit DOCSIS 3.1 das heißt wenn ich vielleicht mal wirklich einen Gigabit Anschluss hole
Komm einfach
Einfach einfach mal drauf geschissen das ist ja nicht so das ist jetzt irgendwie
Ich gebe mein Geld doch für sonst nichts aus
Das klingt wie mega Scam Shop ist aber die sind gut
Ich habe schon viel bei denen bestellt die haben ziemlich gute Preise die sind saubmäßig schnell in der Lieferung
Und die haben oftmals gute Angebote
Hier soll es morgen wieder lieferbar sein
Ich bin ich kann auch einfach die hier bestellen ist doch vollkommen
Wozu ich brauche ich brauchte gar nichts von den Features
Das einzige Feature was die hier hat was die nicht ist
ISDN
Aber
Da musste kecken
ISDN
ISDN in 2020
ISDN braucht man nicht 2020
ISDN ist overrated
Wollte sich vor 2000 Kernen ein PC kaufen aber bei Bruder zieht er die Grenze
Warum soll ich unnötigerweise mehr ausgeben für was was ich nicht brauche
Gut
Es gibt einen REC
Und warum ist das so teuer
Und warum sieht das so ultra hässlich aus
Ne Metallplatte mitm Loch für die Fritzbox
Was zum Teufels
Ich bin ja ich bin ja für jeden Scheiß zu haben ja
Ich bin ja für also für fast jeden Scheiß bin ich ja zu haben
Aber hier aber hier hört es auf
Aber hier hört es auf
Ich habe auch die Fritzbox immer im REC stehen
Ich habe auch die Fritzbox immer im REC stehen aber
Ich zeige euch mal wo ich die Fritzbox drauf stehen habe und zwar habe ich REC
Nicht ne Schublade
Ja doch
Ich glaube so
Ja keine Schublade so was zum ausziehen
Keine Schublade einfach nur so ne Platte zum ausziehen
Da hab ich meine ganzen nicht 19 Zoll Geräte drauf gepappt
Wie nennt man dann sowas REC
REC rausziehen ne
REC
Das ist keine Schublade
Draw oder so
Das ist auch ne Schublade ja
So ne ausziehbares Ding halt
Fertig
Wie nennt man das wenn es keine Schublade ist
Es ist keine Schublade es ist einfach nur ein Stück Metall
Auf Schienen was man rein und raus ziehen kann
Hm
Tray
Ja fast
Ja
Sliding
Das da sowas in der Richtung nur das es flach ist genau
Aber nicht wirklich
Es ist nur das man es rein raus zieht also sowas bloß ohne so ein Ding vorne
Sliding
Gachibass
Ja sowas hier genau
Sowas hab ich drinne
Sowas hab ich bei mir im REC eingebaut
Und da stehen alle Sachen drauf da steht dann das
Die Fritzbox drauf der alte TP Link Switch also die ganzen Geräte die sonst nicht ins REC reinpassen
Und das ist doch mal viel besser als diese komische
Wo hatten wir es dann eben so dieses komische Fritzbox REC da
Wo hatten wir das Fritzbox REC
Hier
Was du warum das ist auch noch was ist es 2 HE
Monka
Vor allem es kostet so viel wie eine Fritzbox
Schwachsinn
Ich hab das hier draufgestellt gut ist
Und unten an die Füße hab ich einfach ne Runde
Nicht Velcro aber sowas ähnliches wie Velcro dran gemacht
Sowas hier
So fertige
So fertige Klettverschlussdinger sowas hier in der Richtung
Ja sowas das hier
Einfach unten an die Fritzbox unten an den Switch unten an die nicht 19 Zoll Geräte einfach so ein Ding dran gepappt
Dann
Bäm unten auf die Auflage vom REC und gut ist
Billig funktioniert gut
Cooper es sieht aus dem sieht es aus wie was in der Garage stimmt gut nachher wird bestellt easy
Und dann schreibe ich die klein mal an dass ich umstellen will auf meine Fritzbox weil das gute ist ja das seit
2018 oder so
Müssen die dir das ja gestatten dass du deinen eigenen Router verwendest
Sorry Cisco Leute ich meine natürlich dass man seinen eigenen
Router verwendet den Router
Die antworten schon gar nicht mehr die haben schon keinen Bock mehr
Die haben schon keinen Bock mehr
Aha
Die Einschränkungen bei einem Kunden mit Compile Modem sind behoben seit gestern seit gestern
Funktioniert es bei dir noch nicht nimm deine Connectbox bitte zwei Minuten vom Strom
Immer noch Probleme dann schreibt uns ein Message
Aha
Das probiere ich nachher mal aus ich glaube denen ja kein Wort
Ich glaube denen ja kein Wort ich halte das für ultra G Bait
Das ist das ist die typische Wohler von Taktik
Bullshit schreiben in der Hoffnung die Leute noch ein bisschen hinzuhalten
Dank Wohler von haben wir wieder nichts gemacht Beinegüte geht mir das auf den Sack
So weiter geht's
Dann dürfte es aber keine Abbrüche mehr geben ja aber ich habe sie ja noch nicht zwei Minuten aus gehabt
Ich hatte heute morgen nur mal zehn Sekunden aus und hab sie wieder eingeschaltet
Das reicht ja nicht zwei Minuten wenn Wohler von sagt zwei Minuten dann müssen das dann das müssen zwei Minuten sein
Ab zwei Minuten resetet sich der Timer in der Connectbox und entprickt die Firmware dann geht's
Sebaru mir ist auch klar dass das ziemlich auf Schwachsinn ist
Aber ich mache das nachher mal und gut ist weil das erste was mich der Technikmann fragt ist
Haben sie schon ihre Fritzbox resettet
Und wenn er mich das fragt dann sage ich einfach nur dann spiele ich ihm das hier vor
So und leg auf und lass mich nur wieder anrufen
Und wenn er mich fragt
Und wenn er mich fragt ob ich meine WLAN SSL dies geändert habe
Wie das letzte Mal dann kriegt er diesmal den hier
Den Scheiß hör ich mir nicht noch mal an ich hab mich so verarscht gefühlt das letzte Mal von dem Wohler von Mensch
Das ist mir erst im nachhinein klar geworden
Am Anfang hat es mich nicht so aufgeregt ja
Aber ich hab mir da noch mal genau Gedanken gemacht was der mir eigentlich für ein Stumpfsinn erzählt hat
Und hat mich dann mehr drüber aufgeregt als eigentlich notwendig ist
Schau mal im Discord unter random
Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt weiter programmieren oder steht da was wichtiges
Okay also weiter gehts
Muss ich mal stehen geblieben genau
Also fertig erzählt jetzt probieren wir mal ob wir auslesen können
Dass ich den Hörer aufgelegt habe
Und ob wir auslesen können ob es klingelt
Das probieren wir jetzt mal folgendermaßen aus
Wir checken als erstes mal ob der Firmware Upload funktioniert
Weil das ist das was wir ja im letzten Stream in den letzten zwei C++ Streams programmiert haben und gemacht haben
Deswegen geben wir mal hier was aus in der in unserer Main Schleife so nach dem Motto
Oder phone keqw
So das kompilieren wir jetzt und laden wir hoch und gucken ob unser Firmware Update funktioniert
Wir gucken uns keine Bahn an wir gucken uns kein Wim an wir gucken uns auch das hier nicht an
Das hier gucken wir uns auch nicht. Übrigens die Kamera im Hof ist verreckt bei mir Leute
Kennt jemand eine gute WLAN Kamera mit Nachtsicht und Tilt
Hast du immer noch Wodafone? Die ist von heut auf morgen nicht weg
Wie soll das dann funktionieren
Am liebsten hätte ich sie ja geflamed als ich also nicht nicht Wodafone sondern als ich das hier geschrieben habe
Für Wodafone wo Wodafone auch nicht darauf reagiert hat kam gleich die Telekom an die Nadine von der Telekom
Wie ist die andere wie ist die andere von Unity Media
Das das Hotte Unity Media Grill wie hieß sie nochmal
Ich habe keine Ahnung ob das das Hotte Unity Media Grill war
Es war nicht Nadine aber es war auch irgendwie sowas wie hieß sie nochmal
Die uns mal hier auf Twitter im Stream quasi geholfen hat
Wie hieß sie nochmal
Ach egal zumindest war gleich die
War gleich die Telekom am Start und
Am liebsten hätte ich die Telekom geflamed weil die Telekom ist meiner Erfahrung nach zumindest netzwerktechnisch besser
Also ich hatte ja eine Weile Telekom und da gab es eigentlich relativ wenig Probleme
Die Bandbreite die drauf stand hat man auch gekriegt
Aber die Telekom ist genauso genauso nach Scheißladen wie Wodafone
Ich habe euch das ja schon ein paar mal erzählt wo sie von mir Geld haben wollten für einen Telefon Anschluss
Ich glaube in Ludwigshafen
Ich war in meinem Leben noch nie in Ludwigshafen ich weiß gar nicht wo das liegt
Ich glaube irgendwie an der Nordsee doch Ostsee Nordsee irgendwo wo liegt Ludwigshafen
Wo ist das am Rhein
Nee dann war es nicht Ludwigshafen
Heiligenhafen was Heiligenhafen Heiligenhafen Heiligenhafen was
Hier das ist wo ist das
Ach du Scheiße wo ist das denn bei Dänemark irgendwie oder so
Das ist ja fast schon Dänisch Ostsee ist das oder
Ja Ostsee
Das ist da wo Ostsee und Nordsee hier irgendwie zusammenkommen
Hier angeblich habe ich hier einen DSL Anschluss gemietet
Hat mir die Telekom erzählt
Ich wusste gar nicht mal dass das existiert bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo die mir das geschrieben haben
So natürlich haben sie sich etwa an die Telekom gemeldet bei mir
So das haben die natürlich gleich an irgend so komisches Russen in Kassel oder was das sein soll
Nee kein normales abgegeben
Und die haben gegen alles verstoßen was sie machen müssten
Die haben mir nicht dargelegt um was es eigentlich geht
Die haben es nicht begründet
Die haben es nicht erklärt die haben einfach nichts gemacht
Die haben einfach gesagt
Ja sehr geehrter Herr Max wir kriegen ich weiß nicht was es war 400 Euro von Ihnen
Nichts
Weder für was
Die haben nicht mal geschrieben für was
Die haben einfach nur geschrieben im Auftrag von der deutschen Telekom
Kriegen wir 400 Euro von Ihnen so sinngemäß
Die haben nicht geschrieben für was die haben nicht geschrieben
Wo die haben nicht geschrieben warum
Nix
Ich dachte wirklich die wollten mich scammen
Ich dachte die wollten mich scammen
Und da habe ich die Telekom angeschrieben
Und die Telekom hat gemeint ja doch doch das wäre gerechtfertigt
Gut das sagen die ja immer
Das ist immer gerechtfertigt
Und da habe ich da vorm Brief kann man sich ja ausdrücken
Darauf geantwortet
So nach dem Motto dass ich mir Beschwerde
Beim jeweiligen Blargericht vorbehalte
Sollten sie irgendwie einen Schufa Eintrag machen
Nur für den Fall der Fälle
Nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie einen doofen Eintrag kriege
Für was was überhaupt nicht von mir ist
Und dass sie mir verpflichtet sind mir darzulegen
Wie auf welcher Grundlage ihre Forderung beruht
Und dann haben die mir eine Telefonrechnung geschickt
Da stand irgendein Typ an irgendeiner Adresse drauf
Ich habe keinen Plassen Schimmer wer das ist
Und wo das ist
Aber ich stand drauf als angeblicher Vertragspartner
Und man muss ja sagen es stand nicht ich drauf
Es stand halt jemals als Vertragspartner drauf
Der so heißt wie ich
Und ich vermute mal dass die einfach alle Kombinationen Max
Mit dem richtigen Nachnamen über 18 Jahre
In Deutschland angeschrieben haben
In der Hoffnung es bezahlt ihnen jemand 400 Euro
Ich meine Briefe sind billig
Wenn man dafür 400 Euro kriegt ist das nice
Aber auf den Jebait bin ich nicht reingefallen
Also das ist genauso ein gleicher Scheißladen
Ich hab denen nur noch zurückgeschrieben damals
Auch wieder vorm Brief nach dem Motto
Dass sie mich nicht weiter belästigen sollen
Und dass das nicht von mir ist
Und dass sie mich nicht weiter belästigen sollen
Und das hat funktioniert
Nie wieder was von gehört
Wahrscheinlich würde das Briefe schreiben dann zu teuer
Als dass sich das lohnt
Das lohnt
Die eins in der Uhren ist total überflüssig
Es gibt kaum was überflüssiges wie einsen
Die ich in die Uhren mache
Hallo ich will meine eins copypasten
Gut also jetzt mal zur eigentlichen Geschichte
Wir haben unsere Firmware angepasst
Und zwar dass wir jetzt in der Hauptschleife Vodafone Crack V ausgehen
Muss natürlich sein
Wichtig, Documents, Platform, Projects, Crack V
Haben wir das Crack V genannt das Projekt?
Gott das heißt auch noch Crack V
Warum heißt das Crack V?
Run
Und jetzt laden wir die Firmware hoch
Also sprich was wir jetzt machen ist
Wir kompilieren die Firmware
Und dann laden wir mit Curl auf die IP hier
Die muss ich übrigens noch ändern
Von dem Microcontroller
Also sprich auf diese IP hier 1.210
Laden wir die neue Firmware hoch
Und das sollte funktionieren
Wenn ich das
Wenn wir das
Wenn das richtig funktioniert dann sollte das klappen
Und ich hab's übrigens falsch gemacht
Gucken
Ich mach das hier mal weg
So, kompiliert
Schauen wir mal ob
Oh
Ja, es ist nicht 430
Es ist 844
Falscher, falscher Port
8443 ist es
Ah, yes, exellent
Update funktioniert, Update läuft
Ja
Boah, das hat aber ganz schön geleckt gerade
Update läuft, easy as fuck
Richtig gut, ne?
Und das ist
Und das Gute ist
Im Vergleich zu den anderen Update-Lösungen
Die es dafür gibt
Es ist komplett über HTTPS
Es macht Checksum-Validation
Ob die Firmware richtig angekommen ist
Und Reboote danach
Passt alles
Also viel besser als alle anderen
So Update, fertigen Update-Libraries
Die es so gibt
So, guckt und ihr seht
Neue Firmware ist da
Keck W aus
So muss das sein
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein ziemlich bescheuerter Test gewesen
Aber wir sehen, dass es funktioniert
So
Das haben wir mal wieder weg
Jetzt gehen wir mal was Sinnvolles aus
Also, ich habe euch ja gesagt, an Pin
An Pin 23
Wie man hier ganz offensichtlich sieht
Werden auch ein bisschen verpixelt
An Pin 23
Hab ich die Klingel
Hier ist die Klingel
Und an Pin
33, glaube ich
Hab ich den
Telefonhörer
Das heißt, probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ob das Ganze
Funst
Wir lesen
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt mal
In unsere Main-Loop rein
Und sagen
Gib mir mal den Wert
Ich muss vorher noch was machen, das habe ich vergessen
Gib mir mal den Wert von
GPIO 33
So, das funktioniert folgendermaßen
Da gibt es bei jedem Arduino
Die Funktion Analog Read
In dem Fall ist Analog sogar
Sinnvoll
Ne, nicht Analog Read, das mache ich dann
Digital Read
Ich kann auch Analog Read
Machen, ist auch okay
Ähm
Das ein
Weil das
An einem
ADC Pin ist
Und der Sensor
Der Magnetsensor
Theoretisch
Mehr messen könnte
Als nur an oder aus
Also wir können ruhig Analog Read machen
Man sieht es trotzdem nachher
Also Analog Read auf GPIO
So
Und danach machen wir den Digital Read
Weil das ist auf jeden Fall nur der 0 oder 1
Digital Read auf
GPIO
23, oder? 23
Excellent 23
So, GPIO 23
Ist die Klingel, GPIO
Ist der Telefonhörer
Und damit das Ganze funktioniert
Müssen wir dem vorher sagen
In welchem
In welchem Zustand
Also in welchem Modus wir
Die Input Pins betreiben wollen
Das macht man folgendermaßen, man kann hier sagen
Pin Mode
Da sagen wir Pin Mode
GPIO, GPIO 33
Ist Input
So
Und eins müssen wir noch
Müssen wir gleich noch machen
Versuche ich dann aber zu erklären
Warum das wichtig ist
Braun war
23 ist keiner im Telefon
Und äh ne
23 ist Klingel
Alter das leckt voll
Warum leckt
Warum leckt das so
Das Vodafone leckt jetzt schon meine
VM
Das macht ja eigentlich Vodafone gerade so
Gucken wir mal ob da einer geantwortet hat
Ähm
Was was
Warum leckt das, was ist denn hier los
23 ist die Klingel
Genau
Also 23 ist die Klingel
Und 33 ist das Telefon
I'm in
Hacker
Hacker Mans sind am Start
So also
GPIO 23 ist die Klingel, GPIO 33 die Klingel
So und was wir jetzt machen müssen
Und das ist wichtig, ich lasse es erstmal
Ich lasse es erstmal weg
Und dann werdet ihr sehen, dass es rumbuggt
So
Der sollte jetzt den Input
Auslesen, also der setzt die Pins
In Input Mode, dass ich da quasi
Sachen einlesen kann und dann liest er sie ein
Und wartet ne Sekunde und gibt immer wieder das gleiche aus
Und dann sehen wir schon
Wenn ich jetzt dort ein Magnet dranhalte
Beziehungsweise die
Die Klingel drücke
In Anführungszeichen
Dann sollten wir das als Signal sehen
Upload wir die neueste Firmware
Ich finde das super
Wie gut das Firmware Update jetzt funktioniert, oder
Einfach zack, einmal einen Curl ausgeführt
Und floop, neue Firmware drauf
Easy as fuck
Hat aber ne Weile gedauert bis wir das
Ordentlich hatten
Und geht sogar relativ schnell
So, neue Firmware ist oben
Reboot
Ja, funktioniert echt gut
Hätte ich am Anfang nicht gedacht
Mit dieser Kack-Library
Diese Web-Server-Library
Ist so dermaßen schlecht und verbugt
So, also wir messen
Auf dem ersten
Sensor für Telefon
Vielleicht machen wir das mal in die richtige Reihenfolge
Also das hier ist Telefon
Und das hier ist Klingel
Wir machen es, wir drehen es hier richtig
Rum, sonst ist das wir
Also wir messen auf
Der Telefon
Auf dem Telefon messen wir
Ne
Umgedreht, oder?
Ich bin verwirrt
Wo ist jetzt was dran?
Telefon ist auf 23, was mache ich denn?
Telefon ist
Guck mal, das laggt, was ist denn da los?
Telefon ist 23
Klingel ist 33
Wie ich das immer falsch rummacht
Wie kannst du Zeilen switchern?
Alt, Alt, Pfeil hoch, Pfeil runter
Das hier ist Klingel
Und das ist Telefon
Exzellent
Ähm
Genau, also wir messen gerade
Auf der Klingel
Äh
Sag mal
Ich bin
Ich bin nicht total unfähig
Die Klingel ist auf fucking 23
Was mache ich denn da?
Klingel ist auf 23
Telefon ist auf 33
Guck da, da steht es doch
Klingel
So, also
Ähm
Du musst echt mal ein VS Code Tutorial machen
Ich kann
Dieses Shortcut
Sag mal, warum hängt denn die VM
so, was ist denn hier los?
Muss ich mal wieder neu starten
Weil Chrome wieder
so viel Platz braucht
Einfach mal Chrome
neu starten, das hilft wahrscheinlich schon
So, easy
Jetzt geht's wieder
Moin, was gibt's heute? Wir machen
den ESP32
Klingelsensor fertig
Und ich hab schon alles angeschlossen
Also wir messen jetzt gerade
Ne, es laggt immer noch
Wir machen
VS Code mal dicht
Wahrscheinlich laggt VS Code
Weil immerhin ist es immerhin noch JavaScript
Ne, was andere
Warum laggt der Scheiß denn so?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Was ist das hier das Problem?
Es
Es keckt mich aus
RAM Belegung
Zeig mal her
Easy, genug RAM
Ich mein, es ist schon mal lächerlich, dass man überhaupt so viel Giga
Dass man 20 GB RAM belegt hat
Mit ein paar Browsern auf, aber
Ich will ja mal, ich will ja mal nichts sagen
Photo App
Wow, die
Die Photo App laggt, die Photo App ist
gecrasht
Windows
Die Foto, die fucking
Foto App ist gecrasht und macht mein
Rechner langsam. Guckt euch mal die CPU
an
100% CPU
Foto App, Windows
Please
Come on bra
Zulul
Wie fand Zulul
Also Windows
Ich weiß nicht, was Microsoft da macht
Aber die machen das irgendwie
Immer
Ich will nicht sagen immer mehr kaputt, das trifft es nicht
Aber immer merkwürdiger
Wie kann das sein, dass eine Foto App 100%
CPU Last verursacht und
1 GB RAM mit 32 GB RAM
Gut
Also, um jetzt zur eigentlichen Sache
Zurückzukommen, wir sehen
Telefonsensor
misst 4095
Das ist, muss man wissen, das ist der
maximalen Wert, der
einen ADC messen kann
Auf dem ESP32, mehr geht nicht
Also sprich, das ist quasi volle Pulle
Und das andere ist, die Klingel ist
auf Null
Das erste, was wir jetzt testen werden, ist
Ich nehme mal ein Magnet
Und wir simulieren jetzt mal das hier
Es leckt immer noch ein bisschen, aber wahrscheinlich
muss er sich erst wieder einkriegen
Wir simulieren jetzt nämlich mal das hier
Indem ich den Telefonhörer
auflege und den Telefonhörer abnehme
Das simulieren wir jetzt mal
mit einem Magnet
Das heißt, ich mache jetzt mal Licht an
und lege mich mal auf die Erde
Und was passieren sollte ist
Diese 4095
sollten weniger werden
Höchstwahrscheinlich Null
Weil der Sensor
nicht mehr kann als an oder aus
Aber theoretisch kann er, glaube ich, Werte
in der Werte dazwischen
Aber ich habe es nie geschafft, diesem Sensor
irgendwelche Magnetfeldstärkenwerte
zu entlocken, sondern immer nur
ist über einem gewissen Wert
Also ich halte jetzt mal den Magnet dran
Und dann sollte der Magnetsensor
höchstwahrscheinlich Null werden
Erstmal Licht anmachen
So, Achtung
Mal gucken
Und?
Hat funktioniert? Ja, ne?
Oder? Ne
Hat funktioniert?
Ich lege es mir mal
auf den Schreibtisch anstatt auf die Erde
Hat nicht? Ne
Hat es recht funktioniert?
Ah, es war auf Null
Ja gut, ich lege es ja auch noch jede Sekunde ein
Ich habe es jetzt auf dem Schreibtisch liegen, jetzt komme ich einfacher dran
Ah, yes
Und habt ihr den Bug gesehen? Guckt mal
Klingel war kurz auf 1
Ist euch aufgefallen? Ist euch aufgefallen, dass die Klingel
kurz auf 1 war?
Das ist ein Bug
Und zwar
Der
Das hat gar nichts damit zu tun
Mit dem oberen Wert, das sah jetzt nur so aus
Das ist Zufall, dass das mit dem oberen Wert
was zu tun hat
Und zwar
Wenn ihr mal Probleme habt, dass
euer Input partout nicht das machen will
Was er eigentlich machen sollte
Nämlich in dem Fall
Mal zumindest fest auf einem Wert stehen bleiben
Dann liegt das da dran
Das man
Das kann man sich jetzt mal merken
Weil da hat man öfters die Probleme
Dass man hier beim Input
einstellen muss
Ob man standardmäßig
Pull up oder pull down
machen will
Also sprich standardmäßig, wenn man einfach nur sagt Input
Dann wird das Ding
Weder auf Null gesetzt
Noch auf 1, also unter der Haube
Funktioniert das folgendermaßen
Ne, das ist kein Bug
Also das führt zu einem Bug
Aber es ist kein Bug
Es ist eigentlich logisch, dass es passiert
Der Pin hat
Keinen definierten Zustand
Der Sensor ist
Aktuell so angeschlossen
Auf der einen Seite
Halt, man sieht es ja hier
Ich zeig es euch mal
Das ist aber was worauf man achten muss
Auf der einen Seite
Hängt der Sensor hier mit
Da sieht man es
Auf Ground und auf der anderen Seite auf 23
Das heißt
Der Pin hier, den ich auslese
Der ist in keinem
In keinem definierten Zustand
Der floated oder
Wie soll man das auf Deutsch übersetzen
Der schwankt
Der
Der schwebt
Also sprich
Der ist irgendwas
Und wenn sich grad der Mond im richtigen
Winkel vor die Sonne schiebt
Dann hast du 1 und wenn er es nicht macht
Hast du 0 oder umgedreht oder was auch immer
Das heißt du kannst dich nicht drauf verlassen
Deswegen, damit man sich
Sicher sein kann, was sein Defaultwert ist
Muss man
Entweder
Den Pin mit Ground verbinden
Oder den Pin mit
Über einen Widerstand mit
3,3 Volt verbinden
Dann ist er entweder
Pull up
Wenn er mit 3,3 Volt verbunden ist
Oder ist Pull down, wenn er mit
Ground verbunden ist
Wenn man das macht, hat man einen
Definierten Zustand von seinem Pin
Glücklicherweise
Haben die meisten
ESP32 Boards
Eingebaute
Pull up und pull down
Widerstände
Das heißt man muss da nichts dran löten
Könnte man machen, muss man aber nicht
Dem Ding jetzt sagen, ok
Ich will, dass du standardmäßig pull up bist
So, wenn ich das jetzt mache
Nee, Moment, ich hab's falsch, falsch nicht Telefon
Ich will nicht das Telefon
Ich will nicht das Telefon, ich will die
Klingel will ich haben
So, dann sag ich, du bist standardmäßig pull up
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt
Nochmal neu flashe
Dann
Sollte der
Standardmäßig auf 1 stehen
Nachdem die Firmware
Flasht ist
Äh, es muss
Immer nen Widerstand dazwischen
Wobei ich mir bei pull down
Gar nicht so sicher bin
Ob das nicht irgendwie
Intern bei, beim ESP noch nen
Widerstand, keine Ahnung, aber man sollte
Immer nen Widerstand dazwischen machen
Aber nachdem ich ja nicht der große Elektrotechniker
Pro bin, muss man da immer
Das mit Vorsicht genießen, aber ich würde nen Widerstand dazwischen machen
Neues Mikrofon
Ne, aber ich hab nen Kompressor eingeschaltet
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal
Wir erwarten jetzt, dass das hier
Auf 1 steht
Aha, und guckt Leute, es steht fest
Auf 1 und floatet nicht mehr
Von 0 zu 1 zu sonst was
So muss das sein
Und das ist nur, weil wir da
Jetzt
nen Pull up Widerstand
Zwischen den Pin und 3,3
Volt damit geschaltet haben
Da muss man drauf achten
Das sorgt für abartige Bugs
Wenn man da nicht drauf guckt
Für Bugs
Wo man echt nicht drauf
Klar kommt
Der Input steht
Wie ne 1
Der war eigentlich so schlecht
Dass er schon wieder lustig war
So
So, ich halte nochmal den Magnet dran
Kannst du mir den
Update Teil irgendwo hochladen
Ja, kann ich, kann ich machen
Machen wir eben Gist, machen wir eben Gist auf
Auf Github oder so
Oder ich push das
Ich kann auch das ganze Teil auf Github pushen
Halt ohne
Secrets File
So, ich halte nochmal den Magnet dran
Äh, hallo
Ah, yes, excellent
Null
Magnet weg
Eins, sehr schön
Übrigens den Magnet
Ich halte den nicht direkt an den Sensor dran
Ich halte den jetzt gerade so
Mal gucken ob was angeht
Ja, so
Zwei Zentimeter drüber
Das ist ein kleiner Magnet
Dafür relativ starker Magnet
Aber nicht so stark wie der in dem Telefonhörer
Also hier in dem Telefonhörer
Haben die schon relativ starken Magnet drinnen
Weil die machen das ja selbst intern
Mit nem Schalter der über Magnet geht
Machst du das Open Source
Ich kann das auf Github hochladen
Da ist ja jetzt nicht so viel drinnen
Hauptsächlich ist die Hardware zu bauen
Aber kann ich machen, ja
Alter, Max würde jetzt
MP2 zocken und nicht hier so
4chan Hacker Stuff zeigen
Tja, einer muss es machen
Guck mal auf Twitch, wer macht es dann sonst
Irgendeiner muss auch
Die BigBrain Community
Bedienen auf Twitch
Wer soll das sonst machen?
Elotrix oder was?
Deine Meinung zu Flutter
Ähm, super
Ähm, ich hoffe, dass es irgendwann
Nochmal für Desktop
Ordentlich funktioniert
Aber nachdem du gerade MP2 gesagt hast
Eine Sache habe ich noch für dich
Dann ist es wirklich ein bisschen MP2, ne?
Sehbaro, ich guck 0, ist das so?
Okay
Reaction Streamer
Warum werden die alle Reaction Streamer?
Oder warum
Reaktieren die alle wie verrückt?
Ich muss nicht
Alles verstehen
Ich bin ja auch mit 35
Mittlerweile
So, da muss ich das auch nicht verstehen
Weil Eats Bunny
Eigentlich sind die ja
Eigentlich sind die ja nicht so
Sondern eigentlich sind die ja schon
Massive BigBrain
Man kann ja wohl kaum mit weniger Aufwand
Und mehr
Content in kürzerer Zeit
Für maximale Views generieren
Als mit Reactions
Ich sehe das ja
Sonntags teilweise
Sonntags mit
YouTube Reactions habe ich
Teilweise random an die 400
Zuschauer sonntag morgens
Wo kommen die alle her?
Werde doch zu Reaction Streamer
Der zu Reaction Streamer, oh ja
Oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee
Dafür, dass ich da noch nicht drauf bekommen bin
Dann sollte ich doch mal unbedingt
Gleich
Zu
Böhmermann und Konsorten
Disson Montana Black und Montana Black
Flame zurück
Reaktieren
Das ist ja gerade voll angesagt
Ich sehe es gerade
Tatsächlich
Es wird Reaktiert
Wahnsinn
Ich habe letztens
Beim Krieger reingeguckt und das erste was ich gesehen habe ist
TikTok
Finch Compilation Reaction
Keine Ahnung
Aktuelles Reaction
Woll das Ding schlechtern?
TikTok, ja, tatsächlich TikTok
Das liegt bestimmt auch an 5G
Exzellent, das muss an 5G liegen
Wohin alle zu nah am 5G
Mast und sie werden wahrscheinlich
Auch von Bill Gates gesponsort
Da wissen wir ja, dass da was im Busch ist, wenn da Bill Gates dran
Beteiligt ist
Wohin davon will ich nicht antworten, die haben das letzte Mal
Auch noch nicht geantwortet, normalerweise antworten die ja immer
Aber die haben glaube ich gerade keinen Bock
Und werden zu sehr voll gespammt
So, machen wir mal weiter
Jetzt kommt
Der Moment der Wahrheit, ob die Klingel
Funktioniert, ob mein
Komisches
Meine komische Loot Action funktioniert
Hat
Mit der Klingel, also probieren wir mal aus
Ich werde jetzt mal
Das 24 Volt
Netzteil reinstöpseln
Und dann schalte ich es mal ein
Und dann sollte
Aus der 1 hier eigentlich eine 0
Werden, wenn das funktioniert
Weil, warum
Ich zeige es mal kurz, man kann es hier ungefähr erkennen
Mit meinem Big Brain Foto
Was ich da gemacht habe
Das Ding ist angeschlossen
Hier einmal auf Ground und einmal auf
Pin 23, so Pin 23
Ist hier Pull Up auf High
Also auf 1
Und wenn ich das
Jetzt schalte, da geht es im Endeffekt hier
Durch
Zu Ground und
Sollte eigentlich 0 werden
Der Vodafone Support schaut Reaction Videos
Vielleicht sollte ich
Ich habe noch eine bessere Idee
Ich
Reakte
Auf Reactions
Vom Vodafone Twitter
Support
Also wir gehen einfach auf den Vodafone Account
Das machen wir jetzt
Wir gehen jetzt auf den Vodafone Account
Und gucken
Wem die geantwortet haben
Und reacten auf die
Antwort Reactions
Melde dich dazu bitte per
PN
Langweilig
Der einzige Nachteil von DSLite
Ich meine, dass VPN mit der Fritzbox
Immer noch nicht über IPv6 geht
Das ist korrekt
Also je nachdem von wo du es machst
Natürlich geht VPN über IPv6
Aber wenn man das aus dem IPv4
Netz macht, dann geht das nicht
Das ist richtig und deswegen ist
DSLite auch scheiße
Bitte melde dich per DM
Aha, Wahnsinns
Per DM gleich privat
Oh Gott
Ah
Mein Brain
Schmerzt
Das ist richtig
Monka Boomer
Ahi
Okay
Wie gut, oh das Quiz
Leute, DSLite Quiz
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken
Wie gut kennst du dich mit DSLite aus
Teste dich selbst
Warum machen die über eine scheiß Technik überhaupt
was?
Mein FFZ hat
Better Twitch TV Emotes ausgeschaltet
Warum?
What the heck?
Gut, also wir gucken uns jetzt mal
das Bonafond Quiz an
Okay
Also chat
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht
aus dem Kopf
Dass es 340
6 Tillionen sind
Aber 123 Millionen
sind definitiv zu wenig
228, ja das ist viel
Aber ich hätte keine Ahnung
aus dem Kopf, dass es 43
6 Tillionen sind
Du brauchst was?
Du brauchst das
Better Twitch TV Emote Care
Kill, okay
Gleich mal gucken, was das ist
Gibt's nicht
Was ist das?
Share the Emotes
Ja, was?
Care, Kill
Gibt's nicht
Gebated
Oder geht Vodafone grad nicht
Doch
Gibt's nicht
Gebated
Ich bin gegen Reaction Streams, also so wie bisher ist cool, aber dieses derzeitige Reagieren
auf Bildungslärm Content ohne einen Mehrwert macht mir echt Kopfdurchschnitt, ja mir auch,
als würde ich jetzt, also mal ernsthaft, als würde ich jetzt anfangen fürs wirklich zu
machen mit Reaction Streams auf Reaction Streams und Reaction Streams, das einzige was ich mache
ist wir gucken uns sonntags ein bisschen YouTube Videos an, also der Slide Quiz,
Tran für die 6 Zillionen, jawoll, richtig, jetzt gibt es nur 3 Fragen, was ist das für ein
Kack-Quiz, 3 Fragen, das kann man, was, sind die jetzt von allen guten Geistern
verlassen, wo davon oder was, ich meine es ist Tungentechno, ich neige zu Tungentechno,
ja, nehmen wir das richtige und nehmen wir absichtlich das falsche Chat, was sollen wir
machen, was nehmen wir, das richtige und absichtlich das falsche, falsch, 1, ok,
falsch, nein, wer hätte das gedacht, gibt es auch keinen zur Auswahl, also ok,
also von allen Sachen ist das noch, kann man sich das noch irgendwie zusammenreiben,
also der Vorteil von DS Lite ist natürlich man hat noch ordentliche IPv6 Adresse,
das ist was, was man mit IPv6 nicht hat und wenn der da, den finde ich gar nicht schlecht,
den kann man tatsächlich rein machen, so also, man hat eine IPv6 Adresse, ok, das ist schon
mal ein Vorteil, man hat eine Fake IPv4 Adresse, die man sich mit allen möglichen anderen Kunden
teilt, auf wo davon gut dünken, schneller ist es auf jeden Fall nicht, also ob ich jetzt IPv4,
IPv6 oder IPv2.5 verwende, ist für die Geschwindigkeit jetzt ziemlich unerheblich,
das einzige was ich mir hier denken kann ist, mit es hat einen höheren Sicherheitsstandard ist,
die machen ja noch mal einen Nutt auf Provider Seite, das macht es nicht wirklich sicherer,
aber das macht es fehleranfälliger, aber man könnte so argumentieren,
dass ein zweites Nutt noch mal sicherer ist, also wirklich ein zweites Nutt ist es jetzt nicht,
ja du wirst ja erst getunnelt und dann, wahrscheinlich ja, ok ich sage jetzt einfach es hat einen höheren
Sicherheitsstandard, ist aber auch schwachsinnig, wenn man sich das genau überlegt, es ist bescheuert,
ok stimmt anscheinend, ok was, machen wir das ganze noch mal, wir beantworten, drei Fragen,
was ist das für ein bescheuertes, für so hängen gebliebenes Quiz, ich dachte da kommen jetzt
wenigstens 15 Fragen oder so, machen wir das alles so, herzlichen Dank, du hast unser Quiz erfolgt,
mehr zum Thema DS Lite, meine Güte, das Internet der Zukunft mit DS Lite, die verkaufen uns Scheiße
als Gold, es ist der Wahnsinn, das können die auch noch ohne irgendwie, ja gut, warum sollten
die das auch, warum sollten die das auch gedankbar machen, mach mal die letzte Frage falsch,
die erklären ja nichts, die erklären ja nichts, die sagen ja nur hier kannst du weiterkommen,
hier könnte das drinstehen, hier könnte die Antwort drinstehen, deine Adresse im Internet,
ja und weiter, ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist Scheiße, weil es massig Probleme macht,
ja und deswegen macht ihr das, ja ok, aber warum ist es jetzt sicherer,
außerdem sind die Sicherheitsstandards höher als bei IPv4, IPv6 unterstützt bei der Datenübertragung
die End-zu-End-Verschüsse, was hatten das damit zu tun jetzt, das ist jetzt ja voll aus dem
Zusammenhang gerissen, was hat denn das eine mit dem anderen zu tun, ok das leuchtet mir nicht
ein jetzt, das ist mir zu, ok im Prinzip verkaufen sie uns Scheiße als Gold, mir leuchtet ein,
dass die Probleme haben, ja weil die haben halt zu wenig IPv4 Adresse und es gibt ja auch keine
IPv4 Adresse mehr, wo sollen sie großartig welche herkriegen, wir hatten auf der Arbeit einen,
der hatte noch einen glaube ich Slash16, komplette Slash16, aber der hat früher auch am Denik
gearbeitet und der hat das wirklich ordnungsgemäß zurückgegeben, ohne zu versuchen da Kapital
daraus zu schlagen, überlegt euch mal was man mit einem Slash16 IPv4 Adressen verdienen könnte,
immerhin darf sie nicht handeln, ja aber man, er hat sie zurückgegeben also muss man echt mal
hoch anrechnen ja, ok was schreiben sie sonst noch und welchen Anschluss geht es denn blablabla,
ok, die Leute, oh Vodafone hat geantwortet Leute, oh Vodafone hat geantwortet, ich hab
gerade eine Nachricht gekriegt, die sagen wahrscheinlich wieder nur bitte schick uns
mal deine Kundennummer per, bitte schick uns deine Kundennummer, das klingt gar nicht gut,
gerne schauen wir uns das an, bitte schick uns dazu eine DPM, mach ich, Vodafone mach ich,
ich mach das jeden Abend jetzt, nach dem Stream jetzt nicht, ich werd das jeden Abend machen,
ich geh euch jeden Tag jetzt auf den Sack, sag mal können die Leute, was macht ihr denn,
macht ihr denn ein Pipe anstatt einen Punkt, Vodafone Service, Pipe, die Dienstleistung,
hat er falsche Tastatur Layout, die Dienstleistung die diese Firmen bietet ist absolut egal,
ich zahle Fitch, Pipe, was ist mit den Leuten lot, Vodafone, ich werd das mit dem Router
neu starten vorher machen jetzt noch mal, dass sie nicht gleich wieder einer ankommt mit der Router
neu starten, Stream hängt dauernd, was ist da los, das ist langweilig Leute, da gibt's
nichts gutes zu reacten bei Vodafone, was man da halt sieht ist, das ist die Ausnahme ist
anscheinend wenn es funktioniert, der Pipe das in den Vodafone, ah stimmt gut, da wär ich gar nicht
drauf gekommen, woher hat er denn Slash16 bekommen, er hat mal beim Denik gearbeitet und hatte damit
irgendwas zu tun, frag mich nicht woher er das bekommen hat, der ist auch schon ziemlich alt,
der geht auch demnächst in Rente, also der war dabei als das doch in IPv4 Adress eine Hülle und Fülle
gab, so wir waren nämlich dabei, dass ich jetzt mal klingeln wollte und gucken, ob es funktioniert,
dass wenn ich klingel, dass hier unten auf Null geht, ich bin mal gespannt, also ich stöpsel es mal ein,
so, schon was passiert, sollte nichts passiert sein, weil ich hab noch nicht angeschaltet,
jetzt schalte ich an, Null, aus, ich hab ausgeschaltet,
sollte das nicht wieder auf eins gehen, sollte das nicht wieder auf eins gehen, wenn ich ausschalte,
ich weiß woran das liegt, das Netzteil hält wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Weile die Spannung,
ich muss wahrscheinlich einfach ausstöpseln, dass es wieder auf Null geht, what, warum geht das nicht
auf Null, auf eins, ist das abgestürzt, Leute ist das abgekackt, das gibt gar nichts mehr aus,
nee das Board ist nicht gesmoked, das blinkt noch, vielleicht ist meine Konstruktion irgendwie
verbackt, gucken, ob Firmware Upload geht, ich glaube die serielle Schnittstelle hat sich einfach
nur ausgeschaltet, kann das sein, ich glaube der Serial Output hat sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
einfach nur ausgeschaltet, ich glaube das wird es sein, gar nichts Schlimmes, wahrscheinlich
habe ich zu sehr am USB Kabel gewackelt oder so, guck dir das Serial Output ist glaube ich einfach im Arsch, oder ich
habe den Serial Adapter gekillt mit irgendwas, nee, ok, was auch immer, ich glaube nicht, dass
was Schlimmes war, ich vermute eher ich habe am USB Kabel gewackelt, dass der Serial Adapter
rausgegangen ist, ok probieren wir das ganze noch mal aus, jetzt ohne daran zu wackeln, ok ich mache jetzt rein, 0 ich mache raus, 1, rein, raus, Funst,
nochmal probieren, mit dem passenden Emote an, Klingel an, Klingel aus, Klingel an, Klingel aus, funktioniert, exzellent,
exzellent, funktioniert, warum hat er im hinten drin einmal live gesagt, weil das ein zweiter Task ist,
den ich im Hintergrund laufen habe, der alle 10 Sekunden auskippt, das mache ich ganz gern, dass ich weiß, dass der Kram funktioniert, auch wenn gerade keine Ausgabe kommt, dann weiß ich nämlich, wenn nach 10 Sekunden nichts gekommen ist, dann ist das Ding verreckt, guck da, der sagt alle 10 Sekunden ich lebe noch,
ja wunderbar, das funktioniert gut, also das heißt schonmal, die Sensoren funktionieren, das ist top, jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch programmieren, dass wir mit den Daten von den Sensoren irgendwas sinnvolles machen können, wir haben es jetzt ja quasi dank Vodafone geschafft, innerhalb von 2,5 Stunden 3-5 Zeilen Code oder so,
also das heißt, das funktioniert, es ist natürlich ziemlich small brain, um nicht zu sagen, schon hier ziemlich low im Kopf, das so zu machen, weil wenn einer nur kurz klingelt, dann kriegt er das gar nicht mit, sei es der Frage, was ich mache, ich erzähl's nochmal ganz kurz, weil vielleicht sind ja in der Zwischenzeit noch ein paar Leute dabei gekommen,
und zwar, ich hab heute mal was ordentlich zusammen gelötet, das letzte Mal war ein bisschen sehr hektisch, was ich da zusammen gewurstet hab, und das backt auch ein bisschen rum, und ich glaube jetzt ist es besser, und zwar was ich zusammen gebastelt hab, ist einmal den ESP32 als Controller,
und einmal einen Sensor, der Magnetfelder erkennt, und einmal, ich nenn's mal einen Sensor, der erkennt, wenn die Eingangsspannung über 24 Volt ist, und wofür ich das verwende, ist für meine Klingel, für das Ding hier, so sieht das innen aus, und das hier sind die zwei Kabel, die von der Gegensprechanlage an der Straße kommen,
und hier ist immer unterschiedliche Spannung drauf, und wenn einer klingelt, steigt das auf 24 Volt, und dementsprechend, wenn ich hier 24 Volt drauf ist, dann weiß ich, das hat einer geklingelt, und das checke ich mit diesem Sensor hier, also unter der Haube sieht das so aus, aber wie gesagt nicht mein Bild hier, unter der Haube sieht das dann so aus, und der erkennt an diesem Input hier unten, ob einer klingelt,
und mit dem Magnetsensor erkenne ich, ob einer den Hörer abgenommen hat, das heißt, was ich jetzt machen kann, ist, wenn ich erkenne, dass einer klingelt, dann schalte ich das Tablet hier ein, und das auf dem Tablet die Kamera anzeigen, vom Hof und von der Straße, bzw. vom Hof und vom Eingangstor,
und wenn einer den Hörer auflegt an diesem Ding, an dieser Stelle, kann ich das Tablet wieder ausschalten, also sprich, funktioniert dann folgendermaßen, bimmel, bimmel, bimmel, dann höre ich, dass es klingelt, und in der Zeit, wo ich aufstehe und dahin laufe, das dauert ja auch 3-4 Sekunden, wenn ich schnell bin, bis ich da bin,
dann geht das Tablet an, macht den Browser auf und zeigt mir die Kamera vom Hof und vom Eingang, und warum das Tablet nicht Dauer anschalten, das ist ja im Prinzip Dauer an, das ist ja permanent am USB dran, aber das ist halt nicht das Display Dauer an,
erstens, weil wenn das Display an ist, dann kann es sein, dass der Akku leer geht, und er lädt permanent, also er lädt und entlädt permanent, das ist wahrscheinlich für den Akku nicht so gut, der Stromverbrauch ist gar nicht so wild,
aber der hauptsächliche Grund ist, weil es ziemlich irritiert, ein helles Display im Flur hängen zu haben, das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, vor allem nachts, ja klar, ich könnte es auch machen, dass es nur nachts ist, aber das, das, ach nee, ach nee, aahhh,